foreign
after two days president Jade bolsonaro
finally came out to speak in public but
he did not use his address to the nation
to clearly and unambiguously concede
defeat rather he talked about the
protests that have blocked many of
Brazil's roads
the current popular movements are the
result of indignation and the feeling of
Injustice about the electoral process
in a shorter dress he said nothing about
losing the election although his
authorized his chief of staff to
initiate the transition process as the
law demands
I will continue to fulfill all the
Commandments of our constitution
as he spoke for the second day in a row
Brazil's main thoroughfares remained
blocked by truck drivers who support him
I support this movement because we need
to get Lula out we need to do something
even military intervention
the highway police whose director is
close to bolsonaro has been slow to
enforce the supreme court order to clear
the roads
and so thousands of cars and trucks
remain stuck
some of us are in favor others not I'm
not but I'm trapped here trying to
deliver my cargo
there's a growing belief that the
paralyzation of Brazil's main roads and
highways was not spontaneous and that
the Hope was that it would trigger
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
Brazilians to take to the streets to
demand a new election that has not
happened but it is a clear challenge to
this country's Democratic institutions
and it doesn't bode well for a peaceful
transition of power
president-elect Lula da Silva has named
Vice president-elect Geraldo altmin to
head his transition team but there's
concern
this also now supporters will remain
very organized with the ability to
create chaos and not respect the law
that's very worrisome here in Brazil we
are going to have to coexist with these
events for some time
and judging by bolsonarado's vow to keep
his dreams More Alive than ever it will
be a rocky road for the next government
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Sao Paulo